alors attention interview comme c'est la
première fois qu'on se voit première
fois on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
on ne bouge pas pendant le génial bien
premier souvenir est elle c'est très
beau jeu c'est pas la première fois que
j'arrive à paris
première map sur les fesses dans le
dernier film c'est pas dix ans à l'âge
de 10 ans je me rappelle ces gens vous
aviez fait quoi vous souvenez vous avez
failli faire un incendie a pris jean
attention alors attention pour les
questions suivantes j'ai des réponses et
pas intérêt à me raconter des conneries
premier baiser
quel âge d'abord sur la bouche à quel
âge
à part ça très bien avec qui le prénom
et ça fait ludovic nom cyrill
bah oui c'est comme ça toutes choses
première fois l'amour oui très bien et
le mec avec l âge 24 oui c'est ça ouais
24 ans et c'était dans une voiture la
marque de la voiture s'il vous plaît que
vous écoutiez mozart première fois avec
une fille j'avais 17 ans et demi
première fois 3
je me rappelle plus tu l'as jeu mais
c'était après 17 ans gérard 18 ans quand
tu es bien coincé quand même
première demie première fois beaucoup
pareil 18 19 ans d'accord là aussi j'ai
la réponse attention première photo
bravo jeune et où un tiers première
saudeau et fellation en même temps j'ai
la réponse et c'est à elle était doublée
d'un projet x déjà sur canal
oui
chez les messieurs watchguard
sur littéraire
sa voiture
est-ce que par amour tu serais prêt bref
ce serait que l'accusation que s'il de
kuro est-ce que par amour ou seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois les
chaussettes sales de votre fiancée the
wind si tu nous regardes